When eating spicy foods, I get heartburn, what does this need, and how can I get rid of it?
Well, we had a question last week about heartburn, and my answer was you do want to check
if you have a high edal hernia.
So remember what I said last week about what a high edal hernia is, is when your stomach
can puritate up in through the hiatus, the whole in your diaphragm.
So it puritates into that sphincter, and then you get a little bubble, the superior side
of that sphincter, and that can belch up acid, and then you think really your problem is
too much acid.
When you eat spicy foods, you get heartburn, it's really most likely because you're not
properly digested them, or if you have a high edal hernia, that the spice in that food
can stay above that diaphragm in that part of the stomach that is herniated above the
diaphragm, and then it can will regurgitate up your throat, and you'll have that heartburn.
So I would definitely check about a high edal hernia, if you don't go to a practitioner
that works out things like that, I actually have a video on our website like I stated last
week, but how to take care of your high edal hernia.
So I'm actually in the video, teaching by staff, how to do it.
So go to our website, cutterspilic.com search, high edal hernia, you'll see a video where
I'm teaching how to pull down the stomach and help with that.
Taking digestive enzymes will be helpful to, most likely, a person that has this, also has
a hypochloridria, which is a decreased stomach acid production.
So look at our, that same website, search hypochloridria, or HCL, hypochloridria, HCL production
in the stomach.
So hypochloridria issues lead to hypochloridria, lead to Hylora issues, lead to hipagestion,
lead to transic factor decrease, B12 deficiency, lead to just about everything.
So look at that, so when you have symptoms, remember your symptoms are telling you something
about something going on, right?
So the worst thing that you could do by spicy foods, and it really bothers my stomach.
So I just take tubs, or I went, got a prescription to a meprizol.
That's like, you know, I'm sorry, but it's that if you just shoot yourself, the pain will
go away too, right?
So don't do that, this makes no sense.
Retreated the symptom with my covering it up, it's like saying, oh, my light comes
out at the car, the engine light, so I fixed it, I put a piece of black tape over it.
That's ridiculous, right?
So I'm trying to bring it to absurdity.
Well, we do that with our body all the time, so you take a drug, or something that will cover
up the symptom instead of saying, this is a symptom of a problem, well, I know the person
is asking this question, probably doesn't do that, because that's why you're asking
the question, right?
So do you get to find out why, how we find out why, so let's just let tonight court process